Позачергові вибори мера Харкова - 31 жовтня. Але задовго до офіційного старту
виборчої кампанії в місті вже почалась запекла боротьба за крісло мера.
Бо хто керуватиме Харковом, стратегічно важливим містом на сході,
матиме значення для усієї країни.
Проєвропейські демократичні сили наразі – аутсайдери, але ними розроблена нова тактика,
яка може спрацювати. "Є кандидат".
Активісти створили групу у Фейсбуці, де будь-хто може висувати своїх кандидатів
на посаду міського голови на позачергових виборах на 31 жовтня.
Зараз є шанс на те, щоб ми вийшли з того стилю керування містом,
який в нас був усі ці роки, який йшов, цей стиль, з 91 року. Радянсько-авторитарний.
Демократично-патріотичні сили нарешті мають можливість поборотися.
Олесь Штефчук - один з ініціаторів створення сторінки "Єкандидат".
Разом з велосипедною спільнотою Харкова він приєднався до Євромайдану в 13-14-му роках.
І для нього та інших активістів це можливість нарешті здійснити одну з вимог Майдану
– отримати в Харкові демократичну владу, яка комунікує, а не придушує громадський сектор.
Активісти сподіваються шляхом голосування визначити найпопулярніших Єкандидатів
і Єкандидаток та запропонувати їх політичним силам Харкова.
Я сподіваюся, що їх буде не три, а хоча б 10.
А далі буде діалог вже навколо цього з політичними силами.
Все одне ми без них не можемо, все одне доведеться домовлятися саме їм.
Бо в нас немає такого ресурсу, щоб вивести свого кандидата.
Активісти відхрещуються від будь-яких фінансових зв'язків з політсилами.
І поки на їхньому фейсбук-майданчику перемагають не особистості, а ідея.
Мати єдиного кандидата від демократичних, проукраїнських та проєвропейських сил.
До цього ж закликав нещодавно харківські демократичні сили навіть відомий письменник Сергій Жадан.
Лише три партії та рухи проєвропейського спрямування змогли пробитися в міськраду
на місцевих виборах 20-го року. Але єдності між "слугами народу", "Європейською солідарністю"
та місцевим "Блоком Світличної" немає.
Певною мірою через те, що здебільшого дії місцевих депутатів
залежать від позиції лідерів цих політсил у Києві.
У цих фракціях кажуть, що дуже чекають на вибори, аби змінити склад
виконавчого комітету міськради, де поки залишилася команда Кернеса.
Проте чи реальне об'єднання демсил?
Думаю, що частина демократичних сил, не ті, що слухають київське керівництво.
Ми можемо в принципі об’єднатися через те, що немає політичної монополії,
через те, що помер Кернес, а його вплив був суттєвий, як би ми не ставилися до нього.
Але ситуація змінилися і зараз ми маємо шанс консолідуватися.
Цього шансу в минулому скликанні не було і близько.
Чи є в нас достойні і чи будуть проходити праймеріз? Будуть проходити. Є достойні.
Питання на сьогодні відкрите з приводу кандидата від "Слуги народу".
Говорити про те, що партія "Слуга народу" буде підтримувати єдиного кандидата,
про це сьогодні взагалі рано. Навіть не обговорюється.
Єдиний кандидат від демократичних, проукраїнських, проєвропейських сил - це дуже гарна ідея.
Але чи хочуть ці люди, які хочуть лідерами… Чи хочуть вони сідати за стіл перемовин?
Депутат від "ЄС" Абрамічев пропонує демсилам взяти за основу математику
результатів виборів мера та міськради 25 жовтня 2020-го.
"Слуга народу", "Європейська солідарність" та "Блок Світличної" набрали на виборах
сумарно менше 25% голосів. Навіть якби вони діяли у партнерстві,
то не мали б суттєвого впливу на рішення більшості,
представленої  "Блоком Кернеса" та ОПЗЖ, які разом набрали на виборах 59% голосів.
На думку політологині Юлії Біденко, демократичні сили повинні об'єднатися
навколо єдиного кандидата або кандидатки, інакше в них не буде
навіть теоретичного шансу перемогти.
Зараз велика небезпека танку на граблях, який дуже притаманний
харківській продемократичній тусовці, незважаючи на їхні політсили, в які вони входять.
Вона в тому, що може не дійти до фінішного процесу…
Почнеться знана українська традиція, де "там, де два україніці, там три гетьмани".
Тому вже не вперше висуваються декілька начебто  непоганих:
хтось з Євромайдану, хтось з антикорупційників, які представляють громадянське суспільство.
Але при цьому вони роздирають голоси виборців, тому що вони конфліктують один з одним.
Головними конкурентами демсил у Харкові, очевидно, будуть "Блок Кернеса" і ОПЗЖ.
Депутати від цих партій - це здебільшого або люди з власним бізнесом, або колишні чиновники.
Депутати від "Блоку Кернеса", за давньої традицією, взагалі уникають спілкування з пресою.
Але неофіційно кажуть, що з дня смерті Геннадія Кернеса їхня фракція розділилися на два табори.
Одні - за тимчасового керівника міста Ігоря Терехова, екссоратника Кернеса, інші - за Михайла Добкіна.
"Блок Кернеса" на виборах 20-го року набрав 21% голосів, ОПЗЖ - 38%.
Фактично вони теж стоять перед вибором: чи мати єдиного кандидата, одного з двох,
чи висувати когось іншого? В ОПЗЖ теж є прихильники як Добкіна, так і Терехова.
Проте у оппоблоківців, на відміну від "Блоку Кернеса", рішення про кандидата на посаду мера
ухвалюється не в Харкові, а в Києві.
Тут постає питання, чи не може бути хтось з цих кандидатів у наших рядах.
Але в нас є політична рада, вона повинна визначитися з кандидатом.
Поки наша партія не прийняла рішення, кого підтримувати.
Харків'яни теж на роздоріжжі. Останні 14 років містом керували Михайло Добкін та Генадій Кернес.
Причому Кернес 10 років був мером, а до того секретарем міськради при мері Добкіні,
який потім став губернатором.
Обидва були антигероями буремних подій. Вони підтримали Януковича під час Майдану.
З ними Харківщина ледь не стала ХНР, їх переслідували правоохоронці за підозрою
в земельних махінаціях, вони не сходили зі сторінок антикорупційних розслідувань.
Проте вони гордо казали городянам, що роблять для них усе найкраще.
Наприклад, ремонтували за завищеними цінами сквери, парки й дороги.
Часто-густо - ті самі по кілька разів. І на кожних виборах вони мали шалену підтримку.
Але тепер частина їхнього електорату, на думку експертів, перейде до категорії тих, хто не визначився.
Таких людей, за оцінками, може бути приблизно 30%.
Тільки не цей... Йому треба... зробити за те, що він зняв трамвайні колії
з центральної вулиці, щоб його легковики їздили! Треба розумна людина, типо Гєпи!
В Харкові не вміють вибирати. Харків'яни якісь невміняємі в плані виборів.
Вони як от це приліпилися до Гени останні 10 років. Тепер до Міші.
Так от ці ж від Блоку Світличної, хлопці. За них харків'яни проголосують!
В них немає фінансового ресурсу себе показати!
Нічого не зміниться на виборах. Вибір-то в нас невеликий.
Лідера немає. А якщо старі залишаться, то буде все по-старому, а, може, ще гірше.
Треба, щоб мер був господарником. Молодь просувати. Партія не має значення.
Експерти, опитані DW, переконані, що Харків очікують надзвичайно цікаві вибори.
Не виключена як перемога невідомого досі кандидата в політиці, так і те, що в Харкові
спробує перемогти якійсь політик національного рівня.
Можливі і несподівані об'єднання затятих ворогів, і бурхливі скандали
- закиди у використанні адмінресурсу, зливи компромату тощо.
Ми бачимо, що зараз флер Помаранчевої революції, Революції Гідності, він спливає.
І певні кандидати готові вдаватися до заходів, які є не дуже легальними,
які є силовими, не дуже законними. Я дуже боюся такого сценарію в Харкові.
На кону великі ресурси і Харків є "ласим шматком". Боротьба буде доволі гострою.
Колишні активісти Євромайдану не впевнені, що Єкандидат чи Єкандидатка
дійсно збере голоси усіх виборців, які не хочуть старої влади.
Ми в принципі працюємо і на наступні вибори. Якщо зараз не вдасться вивести свого кандидата,
то ми щонайменше познайомимся з ними.
Проте активісти не виключають другого туру виборів і сподіваються, що попри епідемію,
явка буде кращою, ніж на минулих виборах, коли на дільниці прийшло приблизно 30% виборців.
Офіційно виборча кампанія в Харкові розпочнеться 12 вересня, за 50 днів до виборів.
Попередні оголошення партіями своїх кандидатур очікуються наприкінці травня-початку червня.